i just don't know about q anon you do  know i don't know no i don't know you  know if you go out and you want to buy  groceries you need a picture on a card  you need id he wants to host next year's  g7 summit at his own doral golf club  take care of the floors you know the  floors of the forest it's very important  frederick  douglass is an example of  somebody who's done an amazing job and  is being recognized more and more i  noticed ivanka trump the president's  daughter is sitting in for the secretary  of state  remember that incredible night with the  maps  and the republicans are red and that map  was so red from suchin  kendo kerr  to virot  trump tweeting the new york times they  are a true enemy of the people